it's a familiar story we've heard it so
many times in recent years
the employees of a tech company want to
get the company very involved in
leftist social causes it's so important
to use the company for good and
therefore the company's got to go woke
it's a not so familiar solution when
this company
basecamp just told all of their woke
employees
to shut up and then a bunch of the
employees quit
and the company said don't let the door
hit you on the way out we will
examine this brilliant sophisticated
solution
to the problem of wokeness in
corporations by telling the workers to
go pound sand i'm michael knowles this
michael knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from friday is from adjd
who mimics me saying michael whispers
his pitch
for ring and it's not that expensive and
then the newlywed couple that i gave it
to will say i heard that that's true
this actually did occur to me
you know i frequently talk about ring
one of the great sponsors of our show
and i mentioned that one of the beyond
all how terrific the product is
it's not that expensive then it occurred
to me you know the
the couples that i've given this to
listen to this show but that's okay
they're fiscal conservatives too
which is why they love ring so much is
going on at our front doors these days
it has never been more important
to be able to see who's there or what's
happening that is why it's the perfect
time
to upgrade your doorstep with a ring
video doorbell okay
you can see who is outside the door
before you open the door that is great
when i'm on the road and
sweet little lace and cute little june
need to they just want to know who's out
there and it's great for me when i want
to know is it the delivery guy is it the
pizza
is it an in-law i don't maybe i'll open
it regardless but
i would just like to make an informed
decision you can you can know
whether you're in your bedroom whether
you're at the office whether you're on
the other side of the world even if they
don't ring the doorbell you will see
who is out there on the front step and i
don't care
if my listeners if my friends who i've
given this to know that it's not that
expensive
that's a great thing that you get this
cool futuristic fabulous product
and it's just not going to break the
bank do not wait get a special offer on
the ring welcome kit at ring.com
knowles it comes with the rings video
doorbell 3 and chime pro
the perfect way to start your ring
experience go to ring.com
knowles that's ring.com knowles base
camp
oh more like base camp am i right am i
right
finally oh my goodness how long have we
been waiting for a company
to just tell their woke employees
exactly where they can shove
their new leftist ideas the car
the employees go to basecamp which is
just a it's a software company they do
kind of
communication management that sort of
thing
they go to the company they say we've
got to get involved in this cause and
that cause and diversity and inclusion
and equity and this and that and this
and that
and the ceo sent out a note which said
quote
we make project management team
communication
and email software this is the ceo jason
fryde we don't have to solve deep social
problems
chime in publicly whenever the world
requests our opinion on the major issues
of the day
or get behind one movement or another
with time
or treasure these are all important
topics
but they are not our topics at work
other executives at the company pointing
out that when employees are spending all
their time chiming in on well
black lives matter or some social issue
on the official communication channels
that is time that they are not spending
working doing their jobs the things that
they are paid
to do so as a result of this ceo missive
totally common sense stuff
one third of the company's 60 employees
left the company took buyouts and said
get out of here and you know what the
executive said
see ya bye-bye okay
of course they said see you bye-bye the
employees thought that this would be a
big blow to the company
guess who comes out ahead here you've
got the most annoying
useless unproductive counterproductive
employees
they're saying you know if you won't let
us waste more of your time while we get
paid
we might leave the ceo's ceo sitting
there he
says like what's the catch hold on here
you're telling me
that i will not have to deal with you
and i don't have to deal with you wait
hold on is that you're saying i don't
need to do the thing you're demanding
now and i won't have to deal with it in
the future and i'll get a more
productive employee
where do i sign up where's the hell
there's got to be some
hidden text here right no
there were a number of employees who
after they left
said basically the company has told us
well your opinions don't really matter
unless it's directly related to the
business
a lot of people are going to have a
tough time living with that yeah
annoying unproductive
counterproductive people are gonna have
a hard time with that but good employees
are gonna love that they're gonna love
that
because obviously i have
definitive political opinions you
listening to the show probably have some
pretty strong political opinions
but i bet that you would prefer to go
into the office every day
and not have to worry about those
opinions one way or the other not have
to worry about pushing
this view on tax cuts this view even on
immigration this view on that you
probably just want to go do your job
and then go home and spend time with
your family and spend time in your
community and maybe be involved in the
politics of your community
but not have to conflate everything so
that your whole personal life and your
old professional life and your whole
political life they're all the same
thing right
now there is a further step here
so i love what they did i think we
should totally support these guys
but there are three opinions on politics
in the workplace
there's the we need to support every
single leftist cause we need to go woke
because that's now
part of the dominant liberal regime
that's one
the second view is politics shouldn't
have anything to do with our work
and economic choices shouldn't
necessarily have to do with all these
political views that's too i think
that's where most of us
want to be and that's the message that
base camp is trying to
put out here but then there's the third
version which i think is the real
version which is
we need to actively support conservative
companies
companies that in any way break from
woke politics
we need we as conservatives need to
support those companies
and we need to punish companies that
don't and i know that's going to sound
icky to a lot of people
because a lot of us say well i shouldn't
have to make political decisions when
i'm buying sneakers or when i'm buying
project management software or whatever
at base camp but you actually do because
in politics and in war your opponent has
a say in the rules of the game
and what the left has told us is that
every economic decision
that you make is going to be political
and they are going to reward the
companies
that go far to the left and undermine
our political order so you know what
we've got to do if we in
any way want to fight back against that
we need to do the same in the opposite
direction
and we need to actively not use the
project management software
that goes woke and we need to actively
use
base camp or any other company that
resists
the wokeness we have to do that i'm so i
know that we don't want to do that we
want to go back
to the halcyon days of i don't know four
or five decades ago when the companies
did not go woke but this is the world
we're living in now
and we've got to reward companies like
base camp james corville
legendary democrat strategist
he's the guy who looks like an alien
like he can't understand the economy
that guy he is breaking with the
democratic party
on the wokeness issue and he's saying
wokeness is going to be
an absolute poisonous ideology for
democrats
because it's going to show people
how out of touch the democratic party is
it's going to
cause the democratic party to lose the
common sense
we should make clear this is a political
conversation
it's not that james carville and you
correct me if i'm wrong is questioning
any one aspect of what gets lumped into
wokeness
but i think you're saying as a political
strategy
this dog doesn't hunt well now it
doesn't hunt
on on several levels first of all it
sounds it i call it the fact politics of
the faculty lounge
and in my view if you want to in
politics you should speak the language
of the people you should speak
clear direct english and address people
as they address each other not like the
humanities department at amherst wants
you to address
everybody so there is an irony here that
james carville is saying people should
speak very clear english because
james garville has one of the thickest
louisiana accents that
anybody does in public life but his
point is absolutely right
and his point is exactly the point of
antonio gramsci a radical theorist that
we
mentioned quite a lot on this show
because he in many ways
is the godfather of this woke
politically correct ideology that we're
now seeing flourish today but
he he was writing and calling for these
things 100 years ago
the common sense that's i'm sorry i just
missed a plug i talk about this a lot in
my book speechless available now for
pre-order there we go oh man that was a
close one
oh my goodness i can't believe i almost
let that go so
so corville and gramsci are saying
you've got
to hold on to the common sense and if
you have the politics of the faculty
lounge
and you've cut nike saying the american
flag is evil don't
don't post anything with even the betsy
ross flag
and you've got coca-cola saying we can't
have election integrity laws and you've
got
i don't know gillette razors telling
your little daughter to shave her face
because she's going to be a little boy
now or harry's razors or whatever
then that's going to be a big problem
and he's right
for a little while he's right if you do
too much
too fast that's going to be a problem
but
if you take this further and you follow
more closely what people like gramsci
and the critical theorists and the new
left later and
the maoists in the 60s and 70s and all
of these people who followed from them
if you go a little further what you
realize is that gradual change here
taking wars or taking positions of
influence and then exerting that
influence throughout the whole culture
eventually the goal is to transform
the common sense and that has happened
to a large degree
think about your favorite woke
millennial think about even some of the
zoomers the generation below
they are taught from kindergarten or
pre-kindergarten or now i don't know you
start school at age two now or something
you didn't do that when when i was a kid
when i was a youth but now they keep you
in school longer and longer to
indoctrinate you more and more so you
start school at age two or three
and you don't leave until you've got
seven graduate degrees in
advanced lesbian studies
so you're there for a long time and
you're steeped in this idea that
christopher columbus evil george
washington evil
the history of the west absolutely evil
literature well it's sexist and racist
william shakespeare he was probably a
white supremacist patriarch
and you are taught to hate your culture
and even among so obviously the left is
going along with that they're the ones
pushing it
but many many people who are in the
middle many many people who are even
center-right who are those kind of
squishy conservatives
they have bought this line of argument
because the left has in many ways
successfully
transformed the common sense so
carville's right it might cost democrats
some elections in the short term
but they are winning the long game in in
a way james carville is thinking like a
conservative here just in that next
election that next election
but the democrats don't even care so
much about the next election they care
about winning that hundred years war
that long march through the institutions
that conservatives
don't recognize so if we if we don't
push back against that
instead of just gloating and saying oh
well we're gonna do much better in the
midterms now because democrats
are trying to trans the kids or
something if we if we don't focus on the
longer game two then it's not going to
matter if we win an election next year
oh good we won
the congress back okay what's that going
to do if the democrats
are totally shaping the culture they're
going really really hard and maybe that
that gives you you know a
sense of sensationalism and craziness
right now
but you're going to see the effects of
that carry through
in the long haul sort of like when you
go out too late one night and you stay
out and have a few adult beverages
the next morning you're gonna have a
hangover and if you have one i'd highly
recommend
liquid iv when you push your body hard
when you just feel run down it's
extraordinarily important to stay
hydrated liquid iv
can provide two to three times more
hydration than water
alone the company is donating four
million servings
of liquid iv in response to covid19
products are being donated to hospitals
first responders food banks veterans and
active military
liquid iv has donated over 10 million
servings globally
and so all the people who are receiving
those donations they do really good
things they need to stay hydrated and
keep their energy up and everything like
that
and for me for me it's when i go out
with the boys you know and have a few
coca-colas maybe
and i know that next morning it's not my
head's not going to feel
so great you have some liquid iv it will
really hydrate you i've always been slow
to hydrate
i don't like to drink a lot of water
liquid iv makes it very very efficient
get your liquid iv in bulk nationwide at
costco or you can get 25
off when you go to liquidive.com use
code michael mich ael
at checkout that's 25 off anything you
order when you get better hydration
today using promo code michael
at liquidity.com so even many
prominent democrats are realizing now
this wokeness thing is not great in the
short term
i'll show you how crazy this is caitlyn
jenner
who is i suppose the leading republican
candidate for governor now in california
shows you about the state of
california caitlyn jenner just came out
and said
i oppose biological boys who are
trans competing in girls sports
it just isn't fair and we have to
protect girl sports in our schools
on the one hand
good i'm glad i don't like some of the
wording here right because listen to the
wording he says
i oppose biological boys who are trans
competing in girl sports
there is no who are trans there is no
trans identity
there is this contrived idea of the
trans identity
but it doesn't have to do with our
actual human nature one cannot actually
be a boy but you know have the biology
of a girl but
really truly be a boy that is a mistaken
understanding of human nature
and he caitlyn jenner is obviously
buying into this mistaken idea of human
nature so
i don't like that but hey i'll give him
credit that's great i'm glad that he
opposes
boys playing in the girls sports it
would appear that caitlyn jenner has a
more conservative view on transgender
issues than christine gnome in south
dakota how insane is that
shows you the the ramifications of
this woke politics these woke
corporations because
why did christinom cave on the ncaa and
and college sports allowing men to
compete against women
i don't know i don't know for sure i'm
just speculating did she get a call
from some donors from some corporations
did she
realize that she was going to have to
get involved in a long protracted battle
with the ncaa with the universities with
these ostensibly
private institutions that exert a lot of
political power i assume some
some of that had had something to do
with with her decision not to oppose the
the trans issue in sports at the college
level even though she would do it at the
high school level
but i say appears here because i don't
want to be taken in
this is always the problem with caitlyn
jenner on many many issues would caitlyn
jenner be better than
gavin newsom of course frankly he might
even be better as a policy matter on the
transgender issue
but what are we giving away
if we get behind caitlyn jenner for
governor
we are i think embracing the
transgender issue i think we're giving
up our understanding of human nature
even if we might get some slightly
better policy
that's that's my fear here and
that's a big give you know i was talking
to a friend of mine who said
the way the only way conservatives can
endorse caitlyn jenner
is if if they form an organization
called conservatives for bruce
and we only call him bruce jenner and we
basically ignore the fact that he thinks
that he's a woman or or
pretends to be a woman it's a it's a
funny answer and i i think it
it does address the problems that we
have but it's a little too clever by
half right because
caitlyn jenner is if if he is elected he
is going to
put himself out there as a woman people
are going to look up
and say oh he is a woman we are now
acknowledging this even the republicans
are acknowledging this in society and
democrats they're the real transphobes
or something like that
so you lose a lot here i also say
appears because i don't know that
caitlyn jenner really supports this
don't forget christy noam talked to
goodgame on the transgender issue until
the rubber met the road
and then she caved what does caitlyn
jenner really feel here caitlyn jenner
wrote an op-ed in 2018 so not that three
years ago in the washington post
and the headline was i thought trump
would help trans people i was
wrong and this is this is the money line
here in the piece
the reality is that the trans community
is being relentlessly attacked by this
president
relentlessly attacked by donald trump
the most pro-lgbt
president in u.s history waving the
rainbow flag on the campaign trail
says the leader of our nation has shown
no regard for an already marginalized
and struggling community
he has ignored our humanity he has
insulted our dignity
what he has made trans people into
political pawns
as he whips up animus against us in an
attempt to energize the most right-wing
segment of his party
claiming his anti-transgender policies
are meant to protect the country yet duh
he's saying that
people who are very very confused and
take have various physical procedures on
them that make them a little
out of fighting shape shouldn't be in
the military necessarily he's saying
that boys shouldn't
compete against girls he's saying that
men shouldn't use the ladies room
this is the vicious anti-transgender
stuff that caitlyn's talking about he
goes on
this is politics at its worst it is
unacceptable it is upsetting it has
deeply personally hurt me
believing that i could work with trump
and his administration to support our
community was a mistake
the recently leaked dhs memo that
suggests preposterously and
unscientifically that the government
ought to link gender to one's genitalia
at birth
is just one more example in a pattern of
political attacks
preposterously and unscientifically
he says it would be to link one sex to
one's genitals
this guy who i i'm not convinced that
caitlyn jenner even wrote this op-ed
because most of these
celebrities don't write their own op-eds
but
the guy who wrote and or put his name on
this op-ed
has absolutely no business in the
republican party this is insane
and if we endorse this stuff if we
endorse what is in this op-ed
we are not conserving anything because
we're giving up
human nature and we are now saying that
if you believe that men and women are
different you're a bigot and you have no
place in the republican party
uh-uh the people who hold those views
have no place in the republican party
there are some people though look this
is a political winner of an issue
to say boys shouldn't compete against
girls everyone knows that this is true
this is totally common sense the
vast vast vast majority of americans
believe in this which is why
i suspect caitlyn jenner is putting out
these statements here
whether whether it's his campaign it's
putting it out or whether he even agrees
with this who knows
but every governor in america basically
is coming out and saying this
and some of them i suspect believe it
ron desantis just came out and signed a
bill saying that boys can't compete
against girls gave a good reason why
governor desantis a bill of the similar
nature is about to cross your desk you
know sign up
oh yeah we're going to protect our girls
i have a four-year-old daughter
and a one-year-old daughter and they're
both very athletic and we want to have
opportunities for our girls
they deserve an even playing field and
that's what we're doing with what
mississippi did with what florida did i
know what other states are going to do
so i look forward to be able to sign
that into law speaking of
bodily transitions to me the most
interesting part of this clip and you
wouldn't notice if you were just
listening to it but if you've seen this
clip
does ryan desantis look like he's lost
some weight
it looks to me like the guy has gone on
a little bit of a diet
you know his suits used to be kind of
oversized now it's a little bit trimmer
looks a little bit better on camera his
hair is a little bit better done
looks to me almost like this guy is
running for president
and i think it's pretty obvious ron
desantis has been positioning himself to
run for president now for a while and
he's done a great job i
i think he's doing a terrific job in
florida and he's doing a good job at
running for president
i have the only bit of caution i've ever
urged on
everyone jumping on the desantis
bandwagon is just that we need to see
more from him
that's all i've said because in many
ways he he reminds me of chris christie
2020
and by the way or i'm sorry chris
christie 2012. chris christie 2012
was a great candidate he should have
gotten the nomination probably
and at least of the candidates who were
being talked about later on in the race
he was a great contender for that he a
couple years earlier had started losing
weight right and
he really tried to gear up for 2016 and
it was just too late at that point
a state politician said all the right
things did a lot of the right things was
very
adept and i i think that ron desantis is
a better candidate than christy was
but we need to see more from him
i have a lot more trust that desantis
will go ahead and do the right thing
than i would in christie gnome or
caitlyn jenner for that matter
but we've just got to see this because
the republicans have been fooled before
okay we've we've had our hearts broken
we've been
jilted by people that we have elevated
to governorships to the senate to the
house
to the republican presidential
nomination
you know who i'm talking about here i'm
talking about
republicans biggest mistake in a long
time
mitt romney mitt romney in 2012
mitt romney was the one candidate who
was running for president
who could not credibly oppose obamacare
obamacare was the biggest issue in 2009
and 2010 and 2011.
in 2012 that was going to be the issue
on the campaign there was one republican
in america
who could not run on this issue because
he invented obamacare when he was
governor of massachusetts
who was that candidate mitt romney the
one that we ended up nominating
and now mitt romney is persona non grata
in the republican party
and largely for for good reason but
think about this it was not that long
ago that republicans chose him to be our
standard bearer
that shows you how the republican party
is divided is unclear
in which direction it wants to go so
romney was the
governor of massachusetts then he ran
for president then he became senator
from utah
because he's just a rich guy who doesn't
doesn't really matter where he lives
so he became senator from utah but he
had a tough time at the utah
republican convention just a few days
ago
when he was booed off the stage
now someone you're not going to boo off
the stage jordan harbinger
the average podcast listener has six
shows
in rotation so most likely you are not
just listening to my show or
maybe you're just listening to it six
times a day but you know i would i would
like to recommend a podcast
to add to your list the jordan harbinger
show top shelf podcast named
best of apple in 2018 jordan dives into
the minds of fascinating people
from athletes authors and scientists to
mobsters spies
and hostage negotiators without fail he
pulls out tactical bits of wisdom in
each episode
all with the noble cause to make you a
more informed critical thinker
better able to operate in today's world
uh definitely definitely worth checking
out i love it i love perusing lots of
different podcasts
and making sure i don't just get stuck
other than listening to the michael all
show every single day without
fail you know you want to make sure that
you switch up the other ones too you
can't go wrong by adding the jordan
harbinger show
to your rotation it's incredibly
interesting never a dull moment
search for the jordan harbinger show
that is h-a-r-b as in boy i
n as in nancy g e r as in really go do
it right now on apple podcast spotify or
wherever you listen to podcasts
by the way the establishment media are
totally pushing us to be divided they're
totally pushing us toward
civil war ben will be talking about that
on his show today and of course you
gotta sign up for daily wire check out
candace
every day on my show i talk about a ton
of amazing products and services from
sponsors that i love and use
we want to get to know you a little bit
better so that we can choose our
sponsors with you in mind
head on over to dailywire.com knowles
fill out my audience survey to tell us a
little more about yourself
to sweeten the whole experience those of
you who complete this survey
will be entered to win a 1 000 gift card
but you can only take the survey once
per daily wire show so if you want to
increase your chances of winning
one thousand dollars go to listen to ben
to drew
to matt walsh to access their surveys as
well you know i put a great deal of
effort into my
ad transitions smooth like butter we
want to make sure we're transitioning to
the right thing so head on over to
dailywire.com
knowles we'd love to hear from you we'll
be right back with a lot more
the former governor of massachusetts who
became the republican nominee
just what nine years ago
was just booed off the stage in utah
where he is the republican senator my oh
my how things
can change take a listen to mitt
romney's chilly reaction
now you know me as a person who who says
what he thinks and i don't hide the fact
that i wasn't a fan of our last
president's character issues
[Music]
aren't you embarrassed
and i'm also no fan of the president's
yeah sure my friends this is the moment
i was talking about
please thank you show respect
so yeah i understand that uh i have a
few folks that don't like me terribly
much and i
i'm sorry about that oh yeah
you can go all your way but i've been a
republican all my life
tough crowd met tough crowd and and mitt
always presents himself
as he's the adult in the room he's mr
republican i'm the old principal kind of
republican but now you guys have gone
crazy
i've been a republican all my life you
you johnny come latelies
i've been a republican all my life is
that so mitt
let's rewind the tape to when you were
running for senator from massachusetts
against ted kennedy in 1994. were you a
republican all your life
look i was an independent during the
time of reagan bush i'm not trying to
return to reagan bush
my positions don't talk about things
that you suggest they talk about
oh oh i guess you weren't a republican
all your life
i guess during the most important
republican administration in recent
memory before donald trump
and i guess in that there were two terms
defeated the cold war i guess it ends up
being a more consequential republican
administration
mitt romney was not a republican i was
an independent
during the time of reagan bush i'm not
trying to return to reagan bush now he
may have been a republican during that
time and he may have just been lying to
ted kennedy but this is the problem with
mitt romney
i am not saying that i despise mitt
romney i
detest him my he's just
weak that's the problem there are many
things i admire about mitt romney
well that's not there's one his hair i
admire the hair i he's got great hair
but as a political matter romney wreck
represents the
liberal wing of the republican party
just like his dad did
george romney and mitt romney has been
on the wrong side of a lot of issues
here he was on the wrong side of the
reagan administration for goodness sakes
he was on the wrong side of obamacare
he's on the wrong side of blm the guy
was out marching with blm last year
blm was torching the country coast to
coast
starting in minneapolis but not ending
in minneapolis and what does romney do
does he go out and say hey
don't burn down the country hey this is
bad we oppose this organization no he
goes and marches with them
so i think romney got exactly what he
deserves there at
the utah state convention not every
republican who showed up there got booed
mike lee who is a pretty strong
conservative
comes a little bit more from the
libertarian wing but he's still
got his conservative bona fides that guy
got cheered as well he should
he's been on the right side of a lot of
issues but there's a big divide here
which way republican man which way are
you going to go
you've got romney who opposed
the republican president didn't vote for
him i probably voted for joe biden i
don't know who he voted for
in 2020. you've got george w bush george
w bush former republican president
who is now actively working to get
amnesty for tens of millions of illegal
aliens
i think piecemeal probably makes sense
and i think the president
uh if i could be so bold call in
republicans who are like-minded
and say let's see if we can't get
something done
you know border security is always a
touchstone issue on this
and uh americans have got to be assured
that the government's doing everything
they can to enforce the border
but there ought to be a recognition that
without
some reforms uh let me rephrase it
reforming will make it easier to enforce
the border comprehensive
may be too big a reach right now and
something like if they can get daca done
and with some
border enhancement you know plans to
give give republicans comfort and voting
for the bill then all of a sudden
there's confidence to be gained
and then they deal with the work or they
can deal with the undocumented
but yeah that may be a better approach
george bush has been pretty consistent
about this throughout his career he's
said
that he supports
amnesty basically he tried to work on a
big amnesty bill and that that didn't
really work
tried to get the wall built kind of but
that also didn't really work because it
didn't have teeth
he's now saying you've at least got to
get daca daca is for the dreamers right
and the dreamers we're told the dreamers
are these cute little six-year-olds were
brought over
across the border it's not their fault
at this point the dreamers are like 40
years old
and they're not as they're not as cute
when they turn 40.
you know if we deport the dreamers who
will watch their grandkids you know
so yes the dreamers are the big issue
and so we've got to leak
give amnesty to millions and millions
but that's only the first step
because then we've got to give amnesty
to all of them and if you get a little
border security in the meantime that's
okay
that'll be good why is this such poison
for the country right now to talk about
amnesty it's not because of
i don't know racism or this ism or
baptism or this isn't who we are all
these kind of abstract principles
there's a very basic issue here which is
what binds us together
what binds us together i was i was
i had a lovely truly magnificent weekend
i was down in florida
visiting my grandparents i was very
excited to introduce
cute little baby june to his great
grandparents wanted to make it
a priority to now you know he's finally
smiling a little bit
so took june down to see the great
grandparents
and the rest of the family and we were
down there we were seeing my aunts and
uncles we're all sitting around we've
got all sorts of different political
points of view
and some of us are very conservative
republicans some are liberal republicans
some are
left of lenin democrats like one of my
dear aunties
and we're all talking and my grandmother
had this very astute question she said
why is it that america can't be like
this why can't we all get along why
can't we all
have these interesting conversations and
start to persuade one another and
why doesn't the country work like this
and the reason of course is that we have
very little binding us together why does
the family work like that
because we all love each other we all
have a shared experience and a shared
history
and we're invested in one another's
success
and a country can have that but
over time we we've chipped away at these
sorts of things
what unites americans we do we don't
have a common race
some countries are just racial countries
right you think of japan
race binds japan together america has
always had a kind of
bit of a mix obviously dominated by
english
settlers who came from the mayflower and
then later on but there were the english
and then there were the dutch in new
york and then there were alliances with
the native americans they weren't part
of the same polity but they did have
alliances
then you had african slaves brought over
then you had the irish come then you the
italians come then you had chinese
people come and you so you've always had
this kind of melange of
of races and that has increased over
time so you're not gonna have a common
race
we did have a common religion in
christianity that
went away we we don't have a common
religion really anymore and and
the the common religion in america the
christian religion was
was a little strange because there were
all these different sects and
denominations but still broadly
christian
we had a common language which was
english that is dropping by the day
we had a common civic religion right
that was the next thing that abraham
lincoln suggested
in in the lyceum address he says we need
to have a civic religion
where we venerate our founding fathers
we venerate
our constitution our declaration of
independence the the men who built this
country that's totally gone the 1619
project
takes aim squarely at that idea of the
civic religion and blows it to
smithereens and we've now for decades
had
students in schools taught that our
founding fathers were actually evil
we're really great but the founding
fathers are evil and
the constitution is a horrible white
supremacist document
and the the declaration of independence
just seeks to enshrine the property
rights of rich white men those jerks
and so that civic religion is going so
what binds us together
into that totally divided country you're
now going to introduce tens of millions
of foreign nationals
that's that's what's going to bring us
together that's good that kind of
diversity is going to be our
strength that's insane unity is strength
unity is part of the transcendentals
right
that is what binds people together and
so you can have people from different
backgrounds
but they have to be unified in some way
what unifies us right now
until we answer that question i don't
think we should admit another immigrant
it would be bad for them it would be bad
for the country
i'm being slightly hyperbolic but not
much this is an
existential problem for the country
you've got to figure out
what binds you together and you have
forces who are only pushing division
forces from the left because it aids
their social revolution
and some forces from the right from the
old establishment right because it
serves their economic purposes to keep
people sort of divvied up and divided
so that is the old republican party of
the last it's not even at all it's
of the last 20 30 years that's the
republican party it's pushing yet we
need
more amnesty more immigration more open
trade deals that benefit other countries
more than they benefit us
and then you've got the conservative
wing which is
represented wild as it sounds by
donald trump by other people who've come
in
meanwhile are we are we at least moving
in the right direction on that kind of
national unity
no maxine waters that wonderful unifying
figure maxine waters is coming at you
saying
you know look it's not that america
was racist evil terrible but now it's
gotten a little bit better
like tim scott says it's not that it was
bad in the past but now it's better
the republican senator who gave that
that response to the state of the union
no no maxine is saying
we're getting more racist every single
day
is america not a racist country well you
know
i don't know if he was counseled
to say that or whether he really
believes that if he really believes that
then he has missed not only the history
of the country but what is going on
right now as we watched uh the invasion
of the capital on january 6 and
those people following trump saying they
were taking back
uh their government and they were
willing to harm people
uh as a matter of fact uh not only were
they willing to harm people
uh for the uh capitol police who
happened to be
people you know police of color
african-american
they were calling them names uh the
n-word
um every day we have seen
you know this nation get more racist
uh than anybody thought perhaps would be
at this point in time
so first of all there is no reason to
ever take anything that maxine waters
says seriously
she's a very unintelligent woman who is
very clever and shrewd at politics so i
want to give her credit for that
but more than her lack of stuff going on
between the ears
she is so cynical she is
she does not give a wit about the truth
this woman just called for a riot
before the george floyd verdict was
given out she said that if
the verdict doesn't go exactly her way
people need to get in the street and get
more confrontational they've already
burned the country down for six months
so
we got to get more confrontational what
does that mean use a detonate a nuclear
weapon how can you get more
confrontational
this woman was was defending the
violence during the rodney king riots
30 years ago okay this this woman is an
absolute cancer on american politics
and she has the goal she has the
temerity to come out and say
the trumpers they went into the capital
and they
were screaming the n-word do you have
any evidence of this of course not
and they were there was an insurrection
lady you just called for an insurrection
like two weeks ago
but then you didn't need to materialize
because you got the verdict
that you wanted because you pressured
the judiciary just like the president
did
give me a break there is a real
social incentive here for
leftists like maxine waters to divide
people up and get everyone agitated on
race
do you know what the the real racism in
this country looks like well there there
is actual
legal racism in the form of affirmative
action that disadvantages whites and
asians
in university policies and
advantages black people and hispanic
people
and some other groups so that's legal
racism but you know what racism as we
talk about it looks like in america
it looks like a jeopardy winner
having to apologize for showing the
number three
on camera that's the that's the real
racism
i'm i am serious this really happened a
jeopardy winner
uh kelly donahue just was
absolutely eviscerated in social media
because he was accused of
flashing a white power sign what was the
white power sign
he did the little circle with his index
and thumb
and then three what is that it's the
okay symbol first of all and it's also
it's three
you'd see basketball players flash that
when they hit a three-pointer
but he apologized anyway he said i'm
truly horrified with what has been
posted about me on social media i
absolutely unequivocally condemn
white supremacy and racism of any kind
people who know me personally know that
i'm not a racist
but for the public at large it bears
repeating i'm not a racist i reject
whites
and condemn white supremacy and all
forms of bigotry for the evil they are
it's shameful to me to think anyone
would try to use the stage of jeopardy
to advance or promote such a disgusting
agenda nobody would ever not it's not
even close there aren't white
supremacists
it's like what like three people that
you're thinking there's
a zillion bigots in blm there's a
zillion bigots
in antifa there's a zillion bigots in
congress like maxine waters
white supremacy not really a thing but
he goes on he goes during the taping of
my fourth episode i was simply raising
three fingers to mark my third win there
was nothing more i was trying to
indicate
i deeply regret this terrible
misunderstanding stop it please don't
stop embarrassing yourself he goes on he
goes on because he he buys the lie
he buys the lie that white supremacy is
a big gigantic horrible epidemic in
america
and his symbol he could really be
seriously interpreted as okay symbol or
the three symbol it could really be
interpreted to mean
white supremacy and he's got to
apologize i'm sorry i'm sorry it's not
it's not about any of that
these people these race hustlers like
maxine waters they're not trying to
fight white supremacy white supremacy is
not a thing
they are trying to make to elicit the
very reaction
that this poor schlub gave them they're
trying to impose upon you
a new understanding of symbols they're
trying to impose upon your new
understanding of language
they're trying to get you to grovel and
apologize
this jeopardy winner who apologized for
making the
the three sign for making the okay sign
shows you the whole game that the left
engages on
political correctness on woke-ism
they're the same thing they're just it's
a new term
for the same old thing just like
political correctness always changes the
terms they've changed the term even for
political correctness
the trick of political correctness which
by the way is the subject of my upcoming
book speechless controlling words
controlling minds which is available now
for pre-order you can also get assigned
first edition which would be let's just
throwing that out there
the the trick here is that they
politicize all of the terms
this was part of the agenda of the early
theorists in pc and then it became
explicit in the 70s when
when the second wave feminist said that
the personal is the political
so even the way that you wash the dishes
even the way you interact in your most
intimate relations that is political
in some way so now what's so brilliant
about this what's so brilliant about
it's a critical theory
which just puts this harshly critical
lens on everything
is that even if it's ridiculous even if
the idea that the okay sign with the
three
or the three point sign that that stands
for white supremacy how i have no idea
even if that's so preposterous when they
make that claim the very fact that they
do make that claim
and that other people echo that claim
means that now this symbol which
nobody has earnestly meant to mean white
supremacy
now it does come to connote that
by the sheer will of the leftists who
say so
now we have to think about that now if i
make the okay saying hey michael you
want you're gonna
come out and have a drink with us later
sounds great
i make the okay sign this now could be
post it all over the internet i've done
it about a hundred times in the show now
so i'm sure it's already gonna be posted
on the internet
that can be posted now to say michael
supports white supremacy
and a bunch of idiots are gonna go along
with that and even some conservatives
are gonna think well it's what
it's what the symbol means now this is
why the left is so concerned with
appropriating symbols they appropriated
the rainbow for goodness sakes
leftist homosexuals and transgender
people and whatever you know
leftist sexual revolutionaries have
adopted the rainbow flag
i've noticed that my conservative
friends who might be a little bit light
in the loafers you know of
of different sort of sexual persuasions
they don't go around waving the rainbow
flag
unless they're donald trump which was i
thought that was a mistake on the
campaign trail
but they don't they don't post the
rainbow flag in their twitter bios they
don't embrace that symbol
because while the left says that that's
a symbol of their sexual identity
they themselves say no that's really
that's not it that's not that's
representing something that i don't want
to be a part of
that's representing something even other
than sexual desire it's
it's a political symbol and the left
took this political symbol
the rainbow the symbol of hope this
beautiful symbol
that shows us that god's not going to
destroy the world in a flood again and
they say no this is ours now and so now
when you see the rainbow
that is what the symbol means got to be
very careful about that
not give up the symbols to the left we
need to embrace our symbols we need to
lean in we need to offer that
substantive view of politics this is all
to justify insane policy so i'll give
you
to me one of the craziest examples of
politically correct redefinition in the
last few years
is they redefined criminal or convict
to be justice involved person
yes justice involved person which is
ironic because criminals are
injustice involved people right they're
not involved in justice they're involved
in injustice
but why because justice involved person
that sounds okay that sounds nice it
makes them
sort of passive figures california is
now planning to
increase the rate of early release for
76 000 inmates including
about 60 63 000 people who were
convicted of
violent crimes including about 20 000
people who were sentenced to
life in prison with the possibility of
parole so people who did
really really bad stuff they are now
going to see their
ability their chances at early release
increased tremendously
why because it's if you take the leftist
view
of criminal justice it's not their fault
that they went to prison
it's not their fault that they committed
their crimes it's our fault it's
society's fault they're just passive
people and actually you know on the
racial politics side black people are
over-represented in prison among the
convicted criminal
populations so that's evidence of racism
so you got to let him out even if they
committed horrible crimes
plenty of people it's awful it's racism
it's bigotry
so you let people out you let them off
the hook and then what happens they go
commit more crimes
illegal alien jesus layal corona is a 49
year old illegal
he pled guilty to second-degree
vehicular homicide he killed a 24 year
old guy
because he was drunk driving and then he
hit this guy
this guy had a record this guy jesus
had been arrested in texas and new
jersey
but he was never deported the guy should
have been deported the first time a cop
saw him
he's here illegally he's violating the
law but no
because it's not his fault that he came
here illegally it's society's fault it's
our fault that we had borders in the
first place we should have just invited
him in
we take in what two million people more
than two million people a year it should
be four million it should be seven
million
we should take everybody in what's the
effect of that well this poor 24 year
old gets killed if jesus had been
deported like he should have been
that 24 year old would be alive today
because the guy who killed him wouldn't
be here
but no he's not going to be deported now
he's going to get about five years in
prison he'll probably be released early
after three years
then he'll go right back out be just
fine because of sanctuary
policies sanctuary what sanctuary
for whom i think that the left
understands that that's not popular they
know that that immigration is a big
loser issue for them
it is the majority of people in this
country according to
multiple polls want to reduce not just
illegal but legal immigration too
that includes a lot of democrats that
includes a lot of independence they want
to drastically reduce it according to
one harvard-harris poll they want to
bring it down by 50
at least legal immigration too so why
does the left push for this
because while james carville is right
this might hurt them in the short term
they might lose an election or two
although frankly if they
change all the election laws and they
federalize congressional campaigns
they're going to have a distinct
advantage now put into the law
but even if they lose a campaign here or
campaign there they go a little too far
here they're there
in the long run they will have positions
of power they will have an electoral
advantage
not six months or a year down the line
but 10 years down the line
20 years down the line that's going to
give them the long game
so how do we push back against this
we've got to get much more serious
on the electoral front on wielding power
when we've got it but also on these
corporations we might not want to reward
a corporation or punish a corporation or
or make everything so political but if
we want to push back against what the
left has done so successfully
that's the only way that we are going to
do it can't wait to log into my base
camp
right after we end the show i'm michael
also with michael knowles show i'll see
you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 on the matt
wall show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you
your family our country not just
politics but culture faith
current events all the fundamentals if
they matter to you come check out the
show